RUSSIA IS LAUNCHING AN ALL-OUT
INVASION FROM LAND, AIR, AND
SEE.
THAT WAS SEEN FROM EARLIER
TODAY.
LET ME ORDERING AIR STRIKES AND
SETTING INTAKES, AND TROOPS.
THE RUSSIAN INVASION SO FAR HAS
KILLED NEARLY 60 PEOPLE AS THAT
NUMBER IS SET TO RISE.
U.S. OFFICIAL SAID THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DECAPITATE THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT WHAT WE ARE
SAYING NOW IS THE FIRST STRIKE
OF MANY TO COME.
UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING BACK.
REPORTING LIVE FROM THE
UKRAINIAN CAPITAL, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON AND CONTINUES
AT THIS HOUR.
WE ARE SEEING REPORTS OF RENEWED
FIGHTING AND CLASHES IN A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
TODAY JUST OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL
OF KYIV IT WAS A BACK-AND-FORTH.
THEY BROUGHT AN ATTACK ERIC
HELICOPTERS AT TAKEN A STRATEGIC
AIRFIELD, WE ARE LEARNING THIS
EVENING ACCORDING TO THE
UKRAINIAN MINISTRY OF DEFENSE
THAT THAT AIRFIELD HAS BEEN
RECAPTURED BY UKRAINIAN FORCES,
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY INCLUDING
THE NORTH WERE IN THE CHERNOBYL
REGION RUSSIAN TROOPS CROSSED
OVER FROM AND WAS ABLE TO TAKE
OVER FROM UKRAINIAN FORCES AND
TAKE OVER THAT POSITION.
IN THE EASTERN PART OF THE
COUNTRY THERE IS STILL FIGHTING
BUT IN DIFFERENT POCKETS OF THE
REGIONS.
THERE WERE USED AS PART OF THIS
OFFENSE OF AS PRESIDENT PUTIN
ORDERED AN INVASION OVER THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY AND IN THE SOUTH,
RUSSIAN FORK.
IF THEY DO INDEED LAUNCH THAT
LARGER INVASION TO TRY TO
BASICALLY HIT THE CAPITAL AND
MAKE SURE THAT IT DOESN'T HAVE
ANY SUPPORT FROM THE OTHER
UKRAINIAN TROOPS THAT ARE STILL
OPERATING WITHIN THE COUNTRY.
>> Dana: WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ALL DAY AND THESE
VERY TRYING CONDITIONS AND WE
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US ON
THE FIVE.
HIM AND KICK IT JESSE WATTERS
FIRST.
>> Jesse: THE VIBE RIGHT NOW
THE CAPITAL HAS GOT TO BE LIKE
BEING IN THE ALAMO.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA BE
SURROUNDED, AND YOU ARE
OUTNUMBERED, WHAT ARE PEOPLE
THINKING?
HOW ARE THEY FEELING?
DO PEOPLE REGRET NOT LEAVING
SOON ENOUGH?
TAKE US THROUGH IT.
>> WE LEARNED TODAY FROM THE
INTERIOR MINISTER THAT MORE THAN
10,000 WEAPONS WERE GIVEN OUT TO
CIVILIANS WHO HAVE PLEDGED TO
STAY HERE AND FIGHT, THERE'S A
REAL UNDERSTANDING THAT IF THESE
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE ABLE TO CHOKE
OFF UKRAINIAN CAPITAL AS THEY
ARE SUSPECTED TO DO IN THE
COMING DAYS, THIS WILL TURN INTO
A MORE URBAN WARFARE SITUATION,
YOU WILL SEE UKRAINIAN FORCES IN
SOMEWHAT OF A GUERRILLA WAR
FAILER BECAUSE IT WILL HAVE TO
TRY TO PROTECT THE CAPITAL.
THE CONCERN THAT THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY HAS AT THIS HOUR IS
WHAT WE SAW LAST NIGHT AND
THROUGHOUT THE DAY TODAY THE AIR
RAID SIRENS ALL NOT ONLY ON THE
CAPITAL OF UKRAINE ALSO THE
SECOND-LARGEST CITY.
THEY CAN LAUNCH MORE WAVES OF
ATTACKS AND WOULD ULTIMATELY
OVERWHELM THE FORCES THAT ARE
OUTSIDE IN THESE DIFFERENT
MILITARY LOCATIONS.
SO IF THE FIGHT DOES COME INTO
THE CITY, IT WILL LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT, IT WILL BE FAR
BLOODIER AND THAT DEATH TOLL
WILL CERTAINLY RISE.
>> Geraldo: GREAT JOB, VERY
COURAGEOUS OF YOU AND THE REST
OF OUR MATES OVER THERE.
WISH I COULD BE STANDING
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH YOU.
YOU ARE EXPERIENCED ENOUGH TO
GET THE VIBE, ARE THE UKRAINIANS
DETERMINED TO FIGHT THIS OUT?
ARE THEY GOING TO FIGHT TO THE
DEATH, ARE THEY REALLY GOING TO
PUT IT ALL OUT THERE RIGHT NOW,
OR WILL THEY FOLD IN THE FACE OF
THE OVERWHELMING SUPERIORITY OF
RUSSIAN?
>> THEY ARE DETERMINED TO FIGHT
IT OUT, WE ARE GETTING
INFORMATION THIS HOUR THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THEIR CHANCES FIGHTING THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY.
UKRAINE'S ARMED FORCES BELIEVE
THAT'S MORE THAN 60 TACTICAL
BATTALIONS GROUPS HAVE BEEN USED
IN THIS FIGHT SO FAR, WERE
TALKING ABOUT 30s
THOUSAND-60000 TROOPS.
SO EVEN IF THEY TAKE HEAVY
LOSSES IN A MORE URBAN
ENVIRONMENT OR SOME OF THESE
REPORTS THAT WE ARE SEEING FROM
THE EASTERN PART OF UKRAINE
THESE JAVELIN ANTITANK MISSILES
DOING THEIR JOB AND STOPPING
THESE BATTALIONS FROM GETTING
CLOSER AS TO THE LARGE
POPULATION CENTERS, IT STILL
MIGHT NOT BE ENOUGH.
IT MIGHT BE TOO LITTLE, TOO LATE
IN TERMS OF THE WEAPONRY THAT
THE UKRAINIAN FORCES HAVE.
THEY NO LONGER HAVE ACCORDING TO
THE RUSSIANS HAVE ANY AIR
DEFENSE SYSTEMS.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY AIR DEFENSE
IN THE CAPITAL SINCE WE HAVE
BEEN REPORTING HERE.
WE DO HEAR FIGHTER JETS OFTEN.
STILL TONIGHT THERE ARE STRIKES
TAKING PLACE IN UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS ARE WORRIED THAT AS WE
GET CLOSER TO 3:00 A.M., LOCAL
TIME PASS THE TIME THAT THEY ARE
PUTTING OUT END OF THE CAMPAIGN
AND AIR CAMPAIGN VERSUS THE CITY
WILL TAKE PLACE.
>> Jeanine: FIRST OF ALL OUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
UKRAINIANS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
I THINK WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THE
PAIN THAT THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN
THROUGH.
GIVEN WHAT YOU SAID OF ARMING
THE CITIZENS, DO THE PEOPLE IN
UKRAINE UNDERSTAND THAT
ULTIMATELY IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THE CALVARY IS COMING IN TO SAVE
THEM, THEY ARE LITERALLY AT WAR
WITH AN AGGRESSOR WHO IS DOING
THIS IN FRONT OF THE WHOLE
WORLD, HE HAS BEEN MINING THIS
UP WITH WEEKS, AND TANKS AND
SOLDIERS.
AND THE TRUTH IS THAT THERE IS
NO WAY OTHER THAN A SANCTION
HERE THERE TO STOP HIM.
IS THIS THE END GAME HERE?
>> IT CERTAINLY THE END GAME
HERE.
PRESIDENT PUTIN DOESN'T WANT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY TO RUN THIS.
YOU WANT SOME SORT OF PUPPET
REGIME THAT HE'D BE ABLE TO
CONTROL, MUCH LIKE WHAT WERE
SEEING IN BELARUS AS A PRESENT
THERE HAS CALLED RUSSIA
BASICALLY THE SAME COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT PUTIN WOULD LIKE THAT
AT A MINIMUM TO TAKE PLACE IN
UKRAINE.
WHAT IS INTERESTING THOUGH WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE CIVILIANS
HERE WHO HAVE PLEDGED TO STAY
AND FIGHT, THEY UNDERSTAND JUST
HOW GRUESOME AND VIOLENT THIS
WAR COULD BE.
ALREADY THE DEATH TOLL IS RISING
AND SOME LEAKAGE IMAGES THAT WE
ARE SEEING FROM THE FIGHTING IN
THE EASTERN PART OF THE COUNTRY
AND EVEN SOME OF THE STRIKES AND
MISSILE STRIKES THAT TOOK PLACE
IN THE MUCH LARGER POPULATION
CENTERS IS QUITE GRUESOME.
THE ABILITY OF THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY AGAINST CIVILIAN
POPULATION BE QUITE BLOODY.
WHILE THERE IS THIS PATRIOTIC
PUSH FOR UKRAINIANS TO SAY WE
WILL STAY AND FIGHT AND PROTECT
OUR HOMELAND, IT IS CAN BE VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO SO THERE
ARE RUSSIAN TANKS IN THE STREET,
MAKE NO MISTAKE THESE CIVILIANS
WILL BE TALKED TO AND EVEN THE
SOLDIERS THAT UP AND CALLED UP
FROM RESERVE FORCES SAY THAT
THEY WILL STAY AND THEY WILL
FIGHT AND THAT THEY ARE WILLING
TO DIE FOR THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE HEARD THAT MESSAGE
AGAIN, AND AGAIN.
NOT ONLY HERE IN THE CAPITAL BUT
ALSO WHEN WE WERE VISITING THE
FRONT LINES IN THE EASTERN PART
OF UKRAINE.
>> YOU BEEN COVERING THIS
WONDERFULLY ALL WEEK LONG WITH
THE FORCES IN THE EAST WHEN YOU
WERE FIRE, IF YOU MANAGE TO STAY
IN COMMUNICATION WITH THOSE
FORCES IN THE EAST?
YOU KNOW WHAT THE RESISTANCE IS
LIKE, HOW QUICKLY THE RUSSIANS
ARE MOVING?
WHAT KIND OF CASUALTIES FROM
WHERE YOU WERE EARLIER IN THE
WEEK?
>> WE UNDERSTAND THERE ARE A LOT
OF CASUALTIES IN THE EAST, THE
RUSSIANS USE THOSE SEPARATISTS
TO MOVE UP THOSE LIVE VERY
QUICKLY.
AND FROM WHAT WE SAW OUT ON THE
FRONT, THEY WERE LITERALLY IN
TRENCHES.
IN TERMS OF THE ABILITY OF A
RUSSIAN AIR STRIKE FROM A
FIGHTER JET TO TARGET SOMEONE
LIKE THIS IN THE TRENCH, THEY
HAVE VERY LIMITED PLACES TO GO.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE THAT ON THE
LOT OF THE UKRAINIAN FRONTS.
A MEMBER THAT LINE OF CONTACT
HAS BEEN THERE SINCE 2015 WHEN
THERE WAS A PEACE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE RUSSIAN SEPARATISTS
IN THE UKRAINIANS STILL A BLOODY
CONFLICT NEARLY 14,000 DEATHS
WHICH BEGAN IN 2014, WE DO FEAR
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT WE
WERE WITH OVER THE WEEKEND MAY
BE INJURED OR KILLED GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THIS OFFENSIVE HAS
MOVED SO QUICKLY AND THE RUSSIAN
AIRPOWER HAS BEEN QUITE
SIGNIFICANT.
WERE TALKING ABOUT NOT ONLY
FIGHTER JETS TARGETING DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS, CRUISE MISSILES, AND
THOSE GROUND FORCES.
AGAIN THE UKRAINIANS ARE PUTTING
UP A FIGHT AND THEY HAVE HAD A
NUMBER OF THESE BATTALIONS THAT
HAVE COME ACROSS THE BORDER
USING ANTITANK MISSILES AND
OTHER MILITARY BUT THE REALITY
IS IS THIS ALREADY A BLOODY WAR
AND THIS COULD GET FAR WORSE IN
THE COMING HOURS, AND DAYS AS
THE RUSSIAN ARE EXPECTED TO
LAUNCH MORE WAVES OF ATTACKS.
>> Dana: IT SUMMING THAT OUR
VIEWERS MIGHT BE WONDERING AS
THEY WATCH YOU AND STEVE
COVERING THIS CONFLICT.
HOW DO YOU STAY SAFE?
>> LOOK, IT'S BUILT BY PEOPLE
WHO USED TO BE FIELD PRODUCERS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET INTO THE
FIELD ALSO STAYING SAFE IN THE
FIELD SO WE HAVE A MASSIVE TEAM
WORKING WITH US NOT ONLY HERE IN
THE CAPITAL BUT WE HAVE FOUR
TEAMS ON THE GROUND IN UKRAINE
RIGHT NOW AND EVERY THING IS
RECALCULATED.
WE HAVE SAFETY PLANS IN PLACE.
WE EXECUTE THOSE PLANS EACH AND
EVERY DAY.
WE DID LAST NIGHT WHEN THIS
MASSIVE INVASION STARTED.
THE REAL STORY HERE IS NOT THE
JOURNALISTS, SAWDUST, AS THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE.
AS THE CIVILIANS WERE PICKING UP
ARMS TO DEFEND THEIR COUNTRY
TONIGHT.
IT'S THE WOMAN AND CHILDREN WHO
ARE CURRENTLY SLEEPING IN THE
SUBWAY SYSTEM OF THE CAPITAL
CITY BECAUSE THEY'RE WORD ABOUT
AIR CAMPAIGNS AND IS THE
SOLDIERS ON THE FRONT LINE WERE
CURRENTLY RISKING THEIR LIVES
FOR THE SOVEREIGNTY O